Віднині курс на НАТО та ЄС
закріплений в Конституції України.
334 голоси
- і зал Верховної Ради вибухає оплесками.
Але що це рішення дасть на практиці?
Зміни до Конституції не означають, що з наступного тижня
натовські війська братимуть участь в АТО,
а Євросоюз розпочне підготовку церемонії
входження України до євроспільноти.
Поки йдеться лише про затвердження в основному законі
євроатлантичних прагнень та європейської ідентичності країни.
Що аж ніяк не означає, що Кабінет міністрів
активно візьметься за реформи,
Верховна Рада почне швидко ухвалювати
євроінтеграційні закони, а наступний президент
не зможе накласти на них вето.
Для вступу в ЄС та НАТО, як і раніше, потрібно виконати
усі необхідні умови і провести реформи.
Однією з вимог обох організацій
є побудова правової держави.
Крім того, задля приєднання до НАТО
потрібно ухвалити закон про національну безпеку,
реформувати СБУ, міністерство оборони, органи військового управління,
та, зрештою, владнати конфлікт з Угорщиною.
Усі необхідні реформи записані в щорічній національні програмі
"Україна-НАТО". Проте щороку Київ виконує їх,
в кращому разі, наполовину.
З огляду на це, обіцянка української влади
до 2020 року повністю перейти на стандарти НАТО -
здається нереалістичною.
Крім того, за статутом альянсу, його членом
не може стати країна, яка воює або має військовий конфлікт на своїй території.
Враховуючи анексію Криму та війну на Донбасі,
коли майже щодня гинуть українські військові,
частина країн НАТО не бажає вв'язуватися в ці проблеми,
а інші - не хочуть дратувати Росію.
Свої складнощі і з євроінтеграційними реформами.
Усі вони прописані в Угоді про асоціацію
і розраховані на десять років.
Йдеться про гармонізацію стандартів та нормативів у всіх галузях:
від торгівлі, безпеки та авіабудування до прав споживачів,
косметичної продукції та захисту довкілля.
Проте і тут план реформ навіть за даними уряду
виконується вкрай повільно: в середньому на 40% на рік.
А за оцінками експертів - цей показник іще гірший:
13-15 відсотків.
І ще більшою перешкодою для вступу в ЄС
є політична складова:
поки що Євросоюз не готовий до розширення на схід,
а тим паче - за умов агресії Росії
та коли Київ не контролює значну частину свого кордону.
Тож, затвердження в Конституції України
євроатлантичних прагнень та європейської ідентичності -
радше позитивний знак західним партнерам
та сигнал Росії, що Україна остаточно виходить з її сфери впливу.
А ще - спроба закріпити стабільність курсу країни
в її основному законі й не допустити реваншу в майбутньому.
Тепер, якщо хтось з майбутніх президентів
підпише указ про "позаблоковість" України,
повернення в СНД чи приєднання до Євразійського економічного союзу,
це рішення можна буде оскаржити в Конституційному суді.